[Music]
so time then for the press preview first
look at what is on the front pages of
sunday's papers and tonight we'll check
out those headlines with the journalist
and author rachel shabby and the lead
writer at the daily telegraph tim
stanley although tim tells me he's on
holiday at the moment lucky him so let's
check out some of those front pages for
you then starting with the telegraph the
first at-home coronavirus treatment an
antiviral pill is to be offered to
patients by christmas reports the sunday
telegraph the time says doctors and
nurses are feeling angry at not being
able to treat seriously ill patients as
figures show the majority of covid
sufferers requiring most care are
unvaccinated
here's the mirror it has the headline
our loved ones died while number 10
parted with grieving families hitting
out following those reports that a party
was held in downing street last
christmas during lockdown
the observer leads with a poll which
shows trust in politicians to act in the
national interest rather than for
themselves has fallen dramatically since
boris johnson became prime minister
a mother campaigning for tougher child
abuse prison sentences is calling for a
child abuse register after the death of
six-year-old arthur lubingio hughes
that's on the front of the sunday people
the express goes with prince william
talking about how he and his mum would
sing to calm his anxiety before he went
off to boarding school
and the star has a story about former
professional footballer and i'm
celebrity campmate david gillard ginola
who claims he once communicated with a
ghost
and we're joined tonight by rachel
shabby and tim stanley great to see you
both thanks for being with us this
saturday evening let's uh crack on then
starting with the sunday times
remarkable story this rachel um
really because of the the statistics
involved this is all about doctors uh in
critical care scenarios really
frustrated with the number of patients
they're having to look after who haven't
had any vaccination
that's right and you're absolutely right
it's an extraordinary figure 90
of those people who end up in hospital
with covid are unvaccinated and so you
can of course imagine the absolute
frustration of all the staff in
hospitals who are dealing with this of
course
health professionals are
not supposed to be judging people who
come in for care the care is supposed to
be non-judgmental but you can absolutely
imagine the frustration when the vast
vast majority of those people coming in
are unvaccinated when you factor in that
um
20 to 30 percent of critical care beds
are being taken up with uh covert
patients at the moment and meanwhile we
have a 5.8 million
people waiting uh on waiting lists for
hospital treatment we're looking at you
know people who need emergency uh you
know urgent treatment um some cancers uh
cancers where you know tumors really
need to be treated now uh for it to be
effective and and other serious
conditions so this this is an incredibly
frustrating uh situation it has to be it
has to be said that of course cuts to
the nhs are a part of this austerity
cuts you know there are shortages um
that are affecting these figures as well
but the figures over the um unvaccinated
are absolutely extraordinary but tim
people do have the right to choose not
to be vaccinated in this country don't
they and also we know that nurses and
doctors uh are expected to give
non-judgmental care
that is correct uh rachel
quoted perfectly all the statistics i
don't have anything to add to that but i
can quote uh the
head of the chair of the british
association of critical care nurses
nikki credland who the nines the times
quotes are saying all nurses understand
they have to provide non-judgmental care
but what we find difficult is that
giving care to patients who have chosen
not to be vaccinated has a knock-on
effect on other patients and that's the
point
are we going to have a conversation in
this country about mandatory vaccines i
don't know it doesn't feel like we are
quite there yet but it is something
that's being discussed on the continent
and in fact it's starting to happen
greece is going to start applying fines
to people over 60 who have not had the
vaccine
austria initially had a lockdown just
for the unvaccinated very quickly
extended it to everyone but is planning
to lift it and keep it for the
unvaccinated germany is expected to move
towards mandatory vaccinations as well
it should be born in mind that uh on the
continent there are generally lower
levels of vaccination than there are in
this country so one reason why we're not
having the discussion is because the
program's been relatively successful and
the british public seems to have have a
high level of trust in the vaccine but
as the
omicron variant spreads and it might not
hopefully be as big a killer but because
it spreads very fast it's going to send
a large number of people into hospital
as it spreads perhaps this will be a
conversation the british lawmakers start
to feel they have to have about whether
or not we should actually be compelling
people to have the vaccine or in some
way penalizing them if they choose not
to yeah we're hearing uh tonight that uh
potentially omicron does have a reduced
incubation period which might be why
we're seeing these extra travel
restrictions it sort of leads us on to
the next story on the front of the
observer rachel comments made to the
paper from sir jeremy farah the director
of the welcome trust he was a government
scientific advisor but uh stepped down
last month he is saying that progress on
kovi because of omicron
could be squandered as a result of this
new variant
yeah that's right and again you can hear
the frustration in his comments and and
um that also chimes with very many
people who are saying very similar
things uh to what jeremy farah is is is
commenting about here of just
the fact that we haven't managed to get
a grip of this globally that there has
been no
coordinated global attempt in terms of
the vaccine rollout the fact that we
have this variant at all this mutation
uh is because um parts of the world just
do not have the same
vaccine access that we do
um
and you know there's absolutely no
reason for that when you bear in mind
that the vaccines were all produced with
huge public funding
and are now being sort of hoarded by
private you know big pharma companies
making record profits
uh so many countries now are calling for
the vaccine patent to be waivered so
that you know asking drug companies to
share the recipe
so that other countries can make the
vaccines and have access to them
um the uk is one of the foremost
countries blocking that decision uh much
to the growing distress of various other
parts of the world yeah i mean we were
talking about this way back in the
summer when we had the g7 leaders all
getting together making pledges making
promises and yet uh still here we are in
this in this uh position um tim i don't
know if you want to discuss that we're
sort of running out of time and i just
want to get the story in um
from your paper to sunday telegraph
about the covid pill it'd be quite nice
to end this section on on some
positivity
yeah there is hope that antivirals uh
will deal with the cons with the
consequences of catching covert so the
focus might slightly shift away from
vaccination and we'd still be doing that
but also towards being able to treat
kobe once people have it anti-virus is a
part of the campaign that's not been
very widely discussed but what rachel
just said is correct um
many western countries fooled themselves
into thinking that either through mass
vaccination
or through placing barriers around their
country and that they could escape the
worst of the virus and they could get
over it and get back to normal as soon
as possible that's unrealistic first
because we have a globalized economy
people move around and if there are
developing parts of the world that have
a new variant we're likely to catch them
the other problem is that this is a
pandemic it's a virus they develop they
mutate and mutations can actually become
even faster spreaders even if they're
not quite so deadly so it was naive to
think that britain would the government
would say the reason why it hasn't moved
towards lifting the paper or sharing it
is because uh it doesn't want to
undermine the profit motive but it has
also said that it would help to
distribute vaccines in greater numbers
and frankly it's not been distributing
enough if that's its argument don't
don't mess with the patents but do hand
out more vaccines it's not been doing
the latter so until there is a global
effort we are still vulnerable and the
idea that individual rich nations can in
some way buy their way out of this
crisis i i think omicron is is proving
that to be a bit of a fantasy okay
rachel do you want just 10 seconds you
want to come back on that
i know absolutely i mean but the
government the the whole idea that the
market can solve this is ridiculous this
is not a market-led solution
um the idea that companies should be
able to profit from something that was
publicly funded in the case of something
like moderna fully fully publicly funded
the idea that they should then be
allowed to make record profits at the
expense of people in you know parts of
africa who just don't have access to the
vaccine is is absolutely absurd and
a disgrace all right we're gonna have to
leave it there uh we're going to go to a
break we will speak again in a moment
when we'll be taking a further look at
tomorrow's newspapers including this
matt cartoon it's on the front of the
telegraph of course this weekend is a
giddy world of cancelled parties there
are three separate events we won't be
going to that and more in a moment
[Music]
hello again part two of the press
preview rachel and tim still with me um
tim let's have a look at the front page
of the sunday mirror our loved ones died
while number 10 parted this is all about
the claims from the mirror actually that
last christmas there was a big party in
number 10 uh
and yet we were in tier 3
lockdown or certainly tier 3 rules
restrictions and the big question is
the prime minister says no covered rules
were broken and yet a party obviously
happened we were in tier three where the
rules were no mixing indoors with anyone
who's not in your household or in a
support bubble so when is the government
going to explain what went on
unless of course they're all related
it's not impossible this is politics if
you don't work with all your relations
do you can't think of anything worse
uh or they're all part of the same
support bubble i don't know offices were
still functioning i was still working in
an office so
does it
if it's if it's a workplace and there's
a bottle of wine passed around is that
breaking the laws
it's irrelevant really the the point is
is i i thought a lot
of the loved ones they're absolutely
appalled the the people who've lost
relations as a result of kovid who stuck
to the rules
let me just finish the thought uh it's
irrelevant uh in the sense that i
thought a lot of the rules last year
were really stupid and i don't blame
people individually for breaking some of
it's a different case if you're the one
setting the rules and if you're going on
telly to moralize about them and to tell
people they must obey them
if you're the one writing them and
moralizing about them then the very
least you offer us that you owe to us is
to actually live by them yourself and we
had the same problem with matt hancock
uh there he was on telly at least twice
a week telling us to do the right thing
and he he is accused of breaking those
rules himself so that's the problem it's
not necessarily the breaking of the
rules it's the hypocrisy that that's
what really sticks involves okay rachel
yeah it's hypocrisy it's not just that
though is there and by the way look
games nibbles drinks obviously these
were parties i don't think we can
equivocate on that in any way i feel
like the government is just straight up
gaslighting us when it says there wasn't
a breach of the rules obviously they
were parties it's not just the hypocrisy
though it's causing people visible
distress
these things the lockdown rules rely on
buy-in rely on trust um people who lost
lives during that period are obviously
just distressed like pretty much
re-traumatized by the fact that now we
know that you know government
just flattered those rules and so it's
the idea that there's one rule for us
and one rule for them that is so um
demoralizing and so gawling for so many
people there's a story on the front page
of the observer about how trust in the
government is at an all-time low just
five percent of mps uh just five percent
of the population think that mps work
for the public good and when you can see
them just flagrantly
flouting rules like this you can
absolutely see why people are so
disillusioned and lacking in trust and
ultimately that's bad not just for these
politicians are in charge but it's just
it's terrible for our for our democracy
and that very process which relies on
trust okay